how do you install pride back into an
individual and ultimately a battalion
I'm on my seventh 17th year serving in
the British Army I've been in my role
for about a decade and I'm about to move
on to a different job recently I've came
out of my platoon bubble and noticed
there are numerous issues I've
identified and I'm looking to help my
COC in fixing it all right so you aren't
still pride back into a battalion into a
unit into an individual in my opinion
pride comes from hard work mm-hmm pride
comes from discipline pride comes from
performance and pride comes from winning
and how do you win you win from hard
work you win from discipline so that's
the cycle you work hard you stay
disciplined that makes you start to
perform that makes you start to win when
you start to win you get pride and of
course there's a dichotomy there too
because you can work your guys too hard
right you can do that so you have to
balance it then it's funny actually life
was talking about this I think I don't
who's we were with a company and he was
saying when we formed up task unit
bruiser mm-hmm we worked hard we worked
a lot harder than normal task units
worked
we stayed later at work we came in
earlier and you know he was saying hey
when we first the first like month we
were together and and Jacko's got
everyone coming in early and all this
stuff and people are grumbling about it
and why do we got to do this extra stuff
and he's days I gathers people are grown
about but then once we started going
through training and our performance was
above our peers then all of a sudden it
turned from grumbling to like Pride yeah
so that's thing then the guys they
stopped complaining and they start
bragging yeah because you know what
we're too you bruiser you know of course
you're not at work because your ears
asking is weak we are strong you are
weak get away from us we don't
be associated with you hmm so you start
getting that which is you know pride
yeah so I think that's what you got to
do you got to instill the hardwork the
discipline in your team it'll hurt a
little bit of first you got to make sure
you don't go overboard with it and
that'll get you what you want if you
need further references on that read a
book called steal my soldiers hearts by
colonel david hackworth or read about
face by colonel david hackworth he talks
about this does he takes the takes
battalion his battalion in vietnam with
no pride and turns them into people with
a ton of pride how does he do it
make some more card makes him have
discipline and then they take pride in
what they're doing
lead by example yes yes and hackworth he
doesn't change everything at once he
doesn't come in and just go crazy
he starts changing important small
things couple of day huh i think
literally he says two a day could change
two things a day yeah but he did start
off with a big thing if you remember
this he checked in this battalion guys
have radios guys have guitars guys have
little bars set up they got all this
crap and he was a everything that you
can't fit in a rucksack tomorrow morning
in the middle of the compound here and
we're getting rid of it so that was a
big wake-up call for everyone mm-hmm but
it was a it was a wake-up call and also
it was why are we doing this well we're
doing this so that we can move when we
move we won't get hit at night won't get
hit at night we won't lose anybody so
good stuff makes sense